Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto sambha-sambhodassam Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto sambha-sambhodassam
Namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma sambuddhassa homage to the Buddha the blessed noble and fully self-enlightened one so this is the sort of final talk we're in the sequence about the khanda these aggregates are just try and sort of bring everything together and and
and see the reason why the Buddha taught him this way so remember that his main technique was to deconstruct what we experience that's his main technique he's always pulling it apart either he's pulling it apart as a slice of the present moment or as a process so in terms of the present moment he uses the khandhas
and also the six consciousnesses so every consciousness we have must have a base so it's one of the five senses and the mind itself which is the sixth base and as a process he uses dependent origination so if we were to follow the khandhas we have the first split away from the body itself and remember when we talk about the body
In terms of insight, we're talking about how the mind experiences the body.
So that's when we come across these four great elements.
So it's not just moving the body, feeling it moving and things like that and the actual makeup of the body itself is how does the body, how is the body experienced by the mind and we come down to this really basic percepts which are these four great elements of fire, earth, water and air which is temperature, pressure
cohesiveness, elasticity and movement.
So that's, as it were, one type of experience sectioned off from the next thing which is the intellect about perception.
and these perceptions begin at a very basic thing so what we can say is that at all times there's the actual experience of a sensation coming in at one of the sense doors and a representation of it in the mind that's your percept and it's from these percepts which are memories which are basically your memory so you don't have to keep seeing blue and remembering blue it has this memory perception
and these perceptions grow until they become concepts at which point they're really beginning to move into the fourth category which is the Sankara but there's an intermediate stage of these immediate percepts is that when the mind begins to perceive them as either pleasant or unpleasant and that's where you've got feeling and these feelings are the quality
the quality of the actual original stimulus that's coming into the body so you're perceiving it as pleasant and unpleasant now when you watch the breath you see you can just feel it as a gentle sensation but you can also perceive it as something which has a certain pleasantness to it
and at that point it's shifting from just being a neutral feeling a neutral sensation you might say to something which is taking on a certain value in terms of pleasantness at this point you're moving into the area of feeling so that's another perception going on so there's the perception of the actual sensation that's coming in and an added perception of how the heart's experiencing it the heart part of us
the emotional part and the other bit that comes into the body which also the body feels as a perception is the mind in the body so the mind in the body has this emotional content
and that's where you get your mental feelings from so there are those two types of feelings physical feelings such as when you stub your foot and emotional feelings such as when you're feeling happy and excited those are all in terms of the Buddha to be classed as feelings
whether they originate from the body or the mind, they're just feelings.
And the important thing is that they're perceived as either pleasant, unpleasant or neutral.
So there's no way we cannot live in a non-dualistic world at that level.
All our experience is divided into some degree of pleasantness and some degree of unpleasantness.
The next bit is the Sankharas and this is where we have included in there is all our reactions to things, all our conceptualizations, all our emotional life, the higher emotional life, and the way it's put is sanya-sanka-papancha.
So the sanya is all the perceptual memories you've got at the intellectual level.
The sanka refers to all the emotional stuff and the papancha is proliferation.
So that's how we proliferate through these basic sensations and perceptions.
And as you know it gets extremely complicated, concepts like freedom and democracy and things like that.
It begins to move into really very complicated areas.
but from the Buddha's point of view you can always draw it down into one of these categories and the fifth category is cognition now cognition is the way I personally experience it is that the first level of knowing
It's as though, I mean, my own way of explaining it is, it's as though all the information is hitting the screen of the television.
And that screen, as it were, is a position of knowing.
It's a point where there's an immediate cognition of what there is.
Now the reason that this is made a distinction of is because it's to be separated out from the knowing.
Now the whole process of Insight Meditation is to make these khandhas objects.
Normally we're in the khandha, the khandha is our personhood, our personality, our character.
is all included within that, the khandhas.
And in our meditation, we're sort of pushing them away from us to look at them.
And in that process of making them objects, right, within ourselves, through our meditation, we're actually beginning to discover this other object.
quality which is the knowing and this knowing has certain qualities about it which is the quality of awareness which is a type of knowing and this intelligence and it's slowly as it were shifting our location
out of the khandhas into this knowing which is the process of awakening so long as we're in the khandhas so long as we are
identifying with an emotion, identifying with a concept, with an idea identifying with a person by which I mean these khandhas identifying with a personality so long as there's that identity we're in a different location when we're meditating and we pull back from that and they become objects to observe we've found a different location we've moved house
Remember the image that the Buddha uses about the house builder, you know, constantly building this house, but I found your ridge pole, I've broken you up and smashed you and all that, it's very violent.
And he's discovered the unconditional citta, you see, the unconditional consciousness.
That's all we're doing, we're just slowly beginning to reposition ourselves in this other place.
so that's the reason why the Buddha teaches the khandhas because in your meditation you can actually as you experience things you can reflect on that you don't have to go into a sort of blank when you meditate you know you can look and then every so often you can as it were reflect upon what you're experiencing and say well that's the khandha you see and this is the way that this knowing knows what it knows
it's one of these paradoxes that the knowing has to pull itself out of the intellect in order to gain its own independence and its own self-knowledge of itself as it were it doesn't know itself, it simply thinks that it is thought it thinks that it is emotion it thinks that it is the body and by making these things objects it's discovering a different identity and
It's that process which we have to keep, just keep reinforcing all the time, which is the process of awakening, see, awakening to a different level of consciousness.
When it comes to the Satipaṭṭhāna, the four places where the Buddha says we have to establish this consciousness, this way of looking, there's four of them, the first one is the body, the second one is feeling, so that's your Vedana, the third one is your citta, that's the word it's used here, which is your sankhāra,
and the fourth one is looking at the dharma looking at what you experience from the point of view of the dharma so that's where you get these five different hindrances the seven factors of enlightenment and included in that are these five khandhas perception is presumed all the way through and the act of cognition is presumed all the way through
you wouldn't know anything without that primary reflection and these things can be experienced it's not as though they are abstract ideas
meditators can actually experience these different things just pulling themselves apart you can experience an emotion for instance against the body and it separates out from the body itself so you can see this is an emotion a mental state which is finer and the body is resonating the body is actually mirroring it but normally we experience it as one thing
You can actually, you know, there are experiences where you can see the original perception, the original feeling, the perception of the feeling and the cognition as a process, as an immediate constant process.
So all these things that the Buddha's talking about are not intellectualizations, they're not sort of something that he's arrived at by just thinking about something, because it makes sense to us from a thought point of view.
If you haven't experienced these, it's absolutely separate.
but they can actually be directly experienced.
So it's the same with the dependence origination.
It's not something that he's intellectualized or conceptualized out of human experience as such.
It's something that you can actually see in your meditation.
So remember that the Buddha has two purposes in his teaching, one of which he really stresses.
It's the negative side, the bit about suffering, unsatisfactoriness, and how we achieve our misery.
And the other part is the end of suffering, just the end of suffering.
This end of suffering is called Nibbāna, it's called the unconditioned, the unborn.
He's got various ways of pointing to it and he talks about it also, remember, as the unbounded, unshackled consciousness.
Unshackled consciousness.
What's it unshackled from?
It's unshackled from various things, but it's mainly unshackled from its identity with these five candas.
so that's your purpose in your meditation and the purpose of knowing these various ways because it's as though in the Buddha's deconstruction of how human experience by looking at it that way you're closer to seeing what he's actually asking you to see whereas if you were to use, shall we say, a Freudian
say a Freudian model so you'd be looking for your superego your ego and your id which is fine you find things it makes sense but would it lead you to liberation this is the point so what I would say is if you want to
you want to be sure that you're on the path to liberation, the path to awakening, then you've got to start seeing the world the way the Buddha sees it, which doesn't particularly negate other ways of seeing it, they may be complementary, who knows, but we definitely have to begin to see the way the Buddha saw things, and then we begin through our meditation to experience that.
I think that brings my little homily for the evening to an end.
I can only hope my words have been of some assistance.
May you be liberated from all suffering by observing the Khandhas sooner rather than later.